[Music]
it's been 150 years since the first
edition of nature was published in 1869
in that time the science contained
inside the journal has changed a lot but
so has the front cover I'm Kelly Krause
creative director of nature and I've
come to the nature archives to discover
some front covers from nature's long
history and to see how the design of the
magazine has changed over the years Wow
right well we have all the nature right
from the first issue on the 4th of
November 1869 when I talked to the
present-day so I'm interested in looking
at the covers over time and how they've
changed from being mostly advertisements
on the cover to being very rich with
imagery part of my job at nature is to
design the cover each week but when the
journal first started the front cover
was completely different to anything we
do today in fact for nearly 100 years
the front page was just used for
advertising you've got this which is
more like announcement
events then you'll get the instruments
that come on the front this is one of my
favorite covers from this era an
advertisement for buying Rock and fossil
collections and there's one here for a
sunshine recorder it really shows how
for a long time science was in many ways
a hobby or a gentleman's pursuit looking
through the archived volumes we
eventually found some covers with actual
science on them but not until the 1960s
and even then it was still only text at
that point it wasn't until a few years
later that we started seeing figures and
black-and-white photography it's so
interesting that in this cover in 1967
the only hint content is this the text
here this is a structure of Jupiter and
then by 1974 we finally moved to
actually visualizing the content as the
main events on the cover finally as we
flick through the books we started
seeing not just black and white but
full-color images filling the pages and
they particularly appreciated the very
of their time gradients that the
popular so this is in the mid-80s when
gradients are really just kind of
starting in a gradients cutouts these
covers were still being physically put
together with tape sir before desktop
publishing all of these designs had to
be made on paper photos were cut out and
pasted down-- ingredients were made by
airbrushing with paint
after being taped together the final
cover was essentially photographed and
the photograph sent to print by the 90s
Nature had embraced desktop publishing
doing most of the work on computers
using software like Photoshop there's a
lot more stuff you can do with an image
once it's digital although some tweaks
are a little more obvious in hindsight
and this is a classic from the beginning
of the desktop publishing era and this
one is one of my particular favorites
because it shows a bit of photoshop
malfeasance this is in 1997 and this is
Dolly the sheep and this cover is
amazing because it really speaks volumes
about the era in which it was made
if you look closely dolly you'll see
that this foot here it looks a bit
strange and the reason is is because
that's actually not Dolly's foot at all
this was cut out in Photoshop and if you
look at the original picture you'll see
that it's Dolly's mother standing behind
it became fashionable to do these sort
of cutouts that were more intricate than
can be done in pasted up so in this she
has a foot that's not her own which is
fantastic when I joined nature I was
given the opportunity to refine the
cover design for the modern digital era
this meant aligning our print and web
design but also as nature's first
creative director making sure that all
covers were evaluated for their artistic
merit as well as the scientific value of
the research they showed I started at
Nature in 2011 so I'm just looking at
some things from that era and they've
landed on actually one of my favorite
covers from the very beginning when I
started which is looking at insect wings
I remember the authors of the paper
submitted about 20 different insects and
this particular one caught my eye
because it was so unusual I think it is
a beautiful photograph but it also says
a lot about the era you know it's still
a Photoshop cutout but it's meant to
look much more natural like it's in a
studio it's meant to give you the sense
that you're just looking at the object
without any decoration really what they
don't yet have here in the archives of
course is our latest cover for nature is
one hundred and fiftieth anniversary
we've collaborated with a team of
network scientists to produce a graphic
representation of almost every paper in
Nature has published since 1900 and I
think it's pretty amazing having visited
the archives and seen the bound volumes
of these papers to then see them
represented like this on the cover and
this cover isn't just a static image we
have also made a video to show the links
between some of the most important
papers in nature's history and an
interactive experience so anyone can
look through the model and navigate
their own way between different points
so this is much more than just a print
cover I think it's a great way to mark
our anniversary
but perhaps in a hundred and fifty years
some future creative director of nature
will be here in the archives looking
over our interactive cover and
commenting on how it's very retro and
representative of its time
[Music]